all right uh one two three four
welcome back to the garda podcast
welcome back to the cardone podcast have
i turned you away yet i hope not
guys uh wow if ren looks like he was
staring into the abyss
it's because he has because he's been
learning houdini
all day and he looks like a man who's
been watching tutorials
on sops vops flops chops and cups
yeah yeah chops cops vop
sops they're basically like sap is like
a surface operator
a vop is a vector operator a cop
is a i don't know do you know that
houdini is the one that gave buster
keaton his nickname buster
really really the houdini harry houdini
is is buster the one who busted him in
the gut and killed him wait was his
first name
gary said no harry
oh harry yeah no wonder he went by
houdini harry
so i'm learning this new program called
harry
so uh i was saying a moment ago before
we had technical difficulties you went
to go get a lacroix and i was reminded
how uh we had gavin over for
gavin from the slimo guys and we were
filming an episode for the guillotine
channel
and we chopped a whole bunch of these
cans in super slow motion it was great
and i forget what happened but i think i
ended up losing a bet or something like
that and i had to chug the entirety of
one of these things in one go
yeah and i did it how'd that go it uh it
was fine i did the whole thing and then
i had
i had so much gas in my stomach from
this that i
had like i had to burp really badly but
when i did
it just came out in one long just like
breath as opposed to like a normal burp
sound effect
and gavin i just he remember i remember
him commenting he was like it sounded
like you just opened a valve invented
it did though it did it sounded like
wasn't it funny because of that or
because he said it with an english
accent well everything gavin says is
gonna be funny because he's got an
english accent
that's true yeah it's that's the one
english
englishman and women if you're listening
that's the one
thing i'm sure we feel you guys probably
hear the same thing when we talk
probably sounds funny maybe yeah i think
new zealand accents
either sounds smarter or it sounds like
funnier yeah new zealand accents are
like the height yeah
the high end of funny angles yeah my
name is made of rocks
yeah we're here to start a revolution
you can say whatever you want in new
zealand accents
get away with it yeah i had a buddy in
college got an
irish what should i do with this should
i just drink this and then
put it on or in between sips gavin
newsom phase right now
what is the proper protocol the newest
line the newest line of masks has a
little zipper right here you just kind
of put it
put the nozzle in and drink it
like a chastity mask yeah yeah are those
real
yeah is
i think the next phase is just like you
just get a hose that's connected to the
mask
and you can just go yeah just slurp it
on up we should get a beer bucket yeah
a beer bucket on top yeah oh i have news
i'm half vaccinated now you are
fascinated i got my first shot on friday
thank you and at first i was a little
hesitant because a friend of mine runs a
vaccine clinic and i was like wait am i
like cutting in line is this like
ethically irresponsible for me to do
he was like yes no he's actually like no
so the issue is that uh a vaccine you
have to store it at a really cold
temperature but once you start thawing
it out
you can't just re-freeze it right you
got to use it or lose it it's like
negative 80 degrees fahrenheit yeah it's
ridiculously cold thanks dip and dots
and i don't okay don't read technology
provided by dip and dots
yeah and so it's like if they don't it's
a then it becomes a logistics problem
they're not able to get enough people to
come in to use all of the vaccines okay
and so at the end of the week they
always have like just a few extras
and so they're like so then the staff
kind of gets their friends in and
i was like this seam sketch right this
seems unethical
and apparently like economists and and
uh
doctors are all saying no actually it is
better for
the world for you to take advantage of
that
they're they're encouraging people to go
ahead and do that
it doesn't matter if you're skipping the
line go ahead and just do it because
the quicker everyone can get vaccinated
the quicker we can get through this
right so i was like okay fine i'm gonna
go do my part
okay so i heard so when do you take your
second
march late late march okay like four
weeks later so i heard i was listening
to
uh game theorists uh they did an
interview with
uh dr fauci the game theorist yeah like
the game theory channel like matpat
yeah pat and his wife uh her name is
sarah
i forget her name yeah um they did an
interview with uh
fauci and um he said in the interview
i don't know what he meant by this and
i'm hoping maybe we can get some clarity
here
from from our educated group of of
commentators here these top scientists
um
but i wanted to ask you guys he said
that the uh
the the vaccination doesn't prevent
you from getting covet it just prevents
you from having symptoms
yeah i mean technically no vaccination
prevents you from getting like the
disease gets into you but then your body
has antibodies to fight it off that's
what i was thinking is like maybe that's
what he meant but
it wasn't it was like one of those sound
cues where i've taken out a context it
was like oh maybe he should
be maybe they should talk to him about
the language that he used for that
because yeah that's confusing
confusing but then i thought about it
and i was like oh that makes sense think
about when you get a flu vaccine you get
the flu
kind of you can catch it but your body
kills it right away
oh i see you're saying because it's got
antibodies yeah so you still catch it
but you don't replicate it and it
doesn't take off and spread through your
system
okay so so can so under this
new vaccine if you take it can you then
spread it to other people
uh no i don't that's what i was confused
i'm not a doctor
yeah from what i know there's still
friends are in-house science
yeah questions of science inevitably
deferred iran
i am the world's foremost expert he's a
neil degrasse tyson of everything
dude i put neil degrasse tyson to shame
with my science knowledge
anyway so i'm gonna expertly talk about
something i'm definitely not an expert
in
uh so the theory what are we talking
about just can you spread it to other
people now
now that you've taken it the jury's
still out it's it's
it's not exactly no there's not enough
data yet to determine whether or not if
you are fully vaccinated can you still
transmit the virus
because like you're saying it's like if
you're fully vaccinated you can still
like
interact with the virus you can get it
into your system
and it just means that you know like
you're saying it's like you can fight it
off you're not gonna like be sick from
it but
it is still possible that you can go
around and spread it to others that
question came in the context of whether
or not you should be continuing to wear
a mask either ever
after you've had covet or you got the
facts and that's exactly it uh i will
continue to wear a mask and pop in
public uh
even if i'm fully vaccinated so just as
a precaution
yeah yeah more or less but the mask is
also a nice social cue to be like hey
i'm taking this seriously i'm trying to
be safe
absolutely but i think things will
change once
like you know someone else is fully
vaccinated then you both can let your
guard down
and then matt can go on a tinder date
again yep and hold them up
saying no to all those requests yep no
thanks not until kovid's over
that's what i said interesting okay well
that was a question we don't have to
dwell on that topic
yeah i just i mean don't like so the
covid it it stays on surfaces though
right for like however long
days or so surfaces aren't that big of a
deal
it's it's more about the air solized
aspect of it it stays in the air longer
than we
initially realized and it's it's all
about breathing you know it's this is a
this is a lung disease type thing it's a
yeah a respiratory illness okay yeah my
point was that we're all surfaces
as well so i don't know if like that it
could spread that way i mean it can
it can you know you can get it from
there feeling good about hurt immunity
coming up here three of my neighbors
have had it
yeah really yeah i haven't been with
them while they had it
two or two of my neighbors uh were taken
to the hospital
via uh fire trucks and ambulances porter
junction the
guy that works there that's the data
that family that owns that place had it
in january and he had to go in and
ventilator and all that stuff oh wow
yeah
he's all he's in the demographic that's
been hit hardest obviously but yeah
of the two neighbors that went only one
came back no
oh man yep yeah yep
you know i'm it's weird that like just
because of like the
culture in america right now around
covid
we haven't gotten to the point yet where
we've really started to acknowledge and
memorialize like the half a million
people that have died
you know it's just starting to get there
but even then like most people like are
either kind of in that denial phase or
just like the
i'm not going to worry about it till
it's over because we got to get through
it phase
which i don't get but like grieve later
at a certain point
we need to do the whole like hey let's
take a moment and like
reflect on the people that you know have
we've lost from this you know
yeah but we haven't gotten there yet
yeah loss is ever present
i don't know where i'm at in that in
that mix but
i do know that it's uh we are doing a
thing for charity
in about two weeks here yes can we talk
about that yet
um
uh i don't know um
well i mean the idea is that we're gonna
i'll save it let's say that yeah we'll
do another podcast and get closer for
that one
but yes we are doing a thing for charity
uh in about two weeks here
specifically covet 19 related charities
yeah um
i anticipate that we'll raise a good
chunk of money for it too hoping so
because we're getting help from somebody
yeah who
has a lot of clout right now dear god
put it lightly
that's a lot of clout um we'll leave it
at that
um piggyback on that topic
without mentioning anything i
uh i bought some bitcoin
funds the other day oh no really yep i
know
see i don't know why did you do that i
just
it was just a seat just so that i'm like
well when did you get when did you buy
it like last week
except okay that's right it's dipped
well it's dipped ten thousand it's
dipped a lot since last time
well what's it at now it's it's it's up
over 50 000 now again
it's all over the place because on
friday nico you are so i saw a bearish i
told him about
it okay so here's the thing here's the
thing here's what convinced me
uh obviously there's an insane
value that 48.9 okay that's i bought it
less than that
so i'm good but it's probably going to
go down but in time
it's probably going to be above that
will it because
it's also highly inefficient it's
extremely inefficient but
it's see i'm testing it i didn't i
didn't invest a lot it's not like i took
my kids college fund and was like here
we go
that's right it was like a couple
hundred bucks you know like just so that
i mentally
yeah like it's in the back of my head
but if you think about it as as
analogous to gold
then maybe
the value is going to continue to go up
slowly in time obviously there's a giant
spike it's completely
in the whims of whatever the hell it is
right now
there's no predicting a value of it of
any kind i'm not trying to say
that there is only reason i did it is
just
like oh let's let's just ride this train
and see you bought a ticket
yeah you're on the cruise ship yeah yeah
um and so
i don't know but if there's only a
finite number of bitcoin
if they don't mind more then technically
you would have a demand supply situation
which i think
the reason for the spike is because of
that people are like oh there's only so
many of these left
yeah well this is
tear me apart in the comments go ahead
this is all speculation can they tear
you apart right now in the comments
probably yeah somebody tear them apart
please
jake i tear you apart
i was like yeah this seems like a clown
train let me buy a ticket and get out
see what's on here i just i find it odd
how like human beings function where
like the moment you're like oh it's
limited
there's only so many well i need some of
that so i can have it a little bit it's
like cool i invented another thing
that's limited and then i invented
another thing that's limited and then i
ended another thing that's limited it's
like all limited
yeah question is how limited niko think
about diamonds
technically technically diamonds aren't
limited because it's made out of carbon
there's a lot of carbon well there's a
there's
obviously a finite supply of everything
in an infinite enough universe
but like
diamonds are valuable right
kinda they're valuable because de beers
said they're valuable 100 years ago and
formed a whole
market around it behind wedding rings
and and like you are
only valuable to your partner if you buy
here the most expensive ring
you can't afford i always hate
that assessment of value like well it's
valuable if people think it's value you
know like
obviously you want there to be inherent
value in something at the end of the day
but that's not always the case either
it's weird
well is there inherent value in art
depends on if you enjoy it hands on if
it's historical yeah if you feel like
emotionally
because it's subjective you know right
so why is
there a 70 billion dollar market for art
i mean there is a
there is value in art there is inherent
value in art and i would point to the
example of music
like i think we've all heard songs that
have made us cry or
made us happy or pulled us from one
emotional state to another
and i think that's there is inherent
value in that
i don't know what it's worth in terms of
dollars or coins
but yeah in a diamond i don't know
maybe i mean is there anything that's
valuable that we don't put a value to
you give a loved one now we're in the
weeds
that's a weed though that's like just
how that's
like that's just how it works it's true
we we
put value into everything that yeah that
exists
i guess there's inherent value in
diamonds if you give a loved one a
diamond and they
like or like you know not to gender
stereotype but like if you give a girl a
diamond she's like
yeah i mean there's it's it's if it's
value whenever people put value into at
the end of the day i mean we're human
beings like all these things they're
shiny rocks
like they're just numbers they're just
baseball cards they're just stuff
it's just a metal that won't corrode
yeah see that has inherent value well
there is that is a good but as people
say
or i think elon musk said this if you
own gold stock or gold things like it's
just a number on paper
as is crypto right yeah it's not like i
bought a
bitcoin i bought an index yeah just like
this yeah just a so technically if you
actually want to own gold or silver you
should go and physically
have some gold and silver right and i do
think that that's
like not necessary at all but also
like if if you can do it
you should do it because if if [ __ ]
really hit the fan
it should really hit the fan ammo is the
currency ammo is dead
brother have you seen the price of ammo
lately
no it's not insane
you'll go to the store to buy bread with
bullets like you won't put them in a gun
ever you're just like all right
two bullets for this slice it's like
cigarettes in prison it's like
yeah she's getting into like fall out
calf territory with that
like she's yeah well and then
you know you can melt down the brass and
do other things with it i guess
you could yeah i don't know you would
though
i'm just riffing here though today's i
think a riffcast if you guys have any
topics that you want to talk about feel
free otherwise i'll keep going on the
my my completely uneducated assessment
of the inherent value of all things
economics with four people who don't
study economics i do i do have an
undergraduate degree in economics oh
just kidding
okay jake actually has economics but
that only gets you so far
like let's be honest it's time to take
off into the trajectory of learning and
fun
and all things interactive because with
today's sponsor brilliant.org
that's exactly what you can do now if
you don't know
brilliant.org is a website and app that
has over 60 courses that help you
understand fundamental concepts
of math science and computer science and
through the interactive experiences
that those courses take you through
you'll better understand the laws
that shape our world now i've told you
guys about some of the math courses some
of the probability courses that i've
taken but another course that i found
really interesting
was casino probability now obviously
casino probability is
just probability in statistics but the
application of them within craps
blackjack and poker
made it much more applicable to
experiences that i was familiar with
i've played blackjack i've played poker
not only did it increase my chances of
maybe winning a little bit more
it also just helped me understand the
game a little bit more which makes it a
little bit more fun to play
in general that's why i wore this slick
jacket today because i felt like i could
walk right into the golden nugget and
put 20 down
right there at the blackjack table head
on over to brilliant.org
corridor cast you can sign up for free
and the first 200 people to sign up
using
brilliant.org corridorcast we'll get 20
off an annual membership all right let's
go back to the podcast
i heard it i read an interesting theory
you know it's kind of why why things
like
the stock market spiked in the pandemic
why things like bitcoin spiked why
things like gamestop has spiked you know
obviously some of those things are
caught up in
trends online and things like that but
you know we are when you have stimulus
spending you do end up with inflation in
certain regards but we haven't had
inflation in a lot
of the consumer price index things which
can be misleading because consumer price
index
generally references things that middle
class to lower class people buy
yeah um now when you do like say a 600
stimulus check or the you know small
business loans things like that
that goes to somebody who's struggling
to pay the rent or
struggling to make ends meet because
they don't you know they lost their job
then you don't get a sudden influx of
cash you just get somebody paying the
rent which
is already happening but if somebody
already has their bases covered
you know they're they're making enough
income that you know a 600 stimulus
check
isn't paying the rent because they
already have the rent paid
then that goes into the stock market or
it goes into investments it goes into
savings you know maybe they go out and
buy something with it a lot of people
just
save it you know because they don't need
to spend it right now and so that's one
of the reasons why you see an
inflation in something like the stock
market but you don't see that inflation
yet in like consumer goods
uh it's a theory just you know that i
read online um a game
theory that's just a theory
but that is something that we're looking
at right now when you you know and
something like when bitcoin
jumps up to fifty thousand dollars uh
coin a bit
um you know you always go like man
bitcoin is so valuable
but you should pause and remember that
you know einstein's theory of relativity
did bitcoin go up in value or the dollar
go down in value
both both yeah definitely same with
it's weird it's really weird like first
of all we operate on this federal
reserve system which is
everyone bashes on the federal reserve
but actually it's it's a very robust
like system that keeps a lot of
things from going wrong but that aside
when you have a bunch of people that
are like take that example
take that 600 and then you save it
well now you took it out of
circulation effectively like yeah it can
go into a savings account and then
the res the reserve rate they can charge
interest on it you know well
and they can invest in other areas but
like it you didn't take it and then
immediately give it out into like some
sort of consumer
product right so that
all of a sudden now it's hard to tell
like
how much how much money is is actually
in the system
yeah um because you don't see as much of
it going around
from transaction to transaction
day-to-day
um you can look at things like bank
reserves and things like that to
understand that but
at the same time um it just it makes it
there's more smoke and mirrors than
there were than there was prior
and so yeah it's it's weird we're in a
really weird
an unprecedented economic time for sure
yeah like uh
uh maybe it'll just things will come
along and maybe it's just maybe that's
just where the value is
and it's like maybe the dow is like 30
000
plus and maybe bitcoins are 50 000 and
maybe
maybe it's all fine maybe i mean i feel
like we're reaching a point where
everybody's like
look i just realized that currency is
totally a made-up thing
so my v-bucks and fortnite are just as
valuable to me as my crypto art which is
just as valuable to me as my theory i'm
like it's all just
that's all the same thing so true though
well that was how ethereum started the
guy whose name vitalik
something i forget his name some kid who
invented ethereum when he was like 19
years old because he was
he wasn't pleased with how bitcoin was
operating
uh he was inspired to do that because he
had
been playing world of warcraft in world
of warcraft you get gold
right and you can actually sell that
gold from in game for real world cash
and then one day uh blizzard kind of
changed the way the
uh world of warcraft economy works and
it overnight adjusted the value of all
of the in-game gold and so it's like
imagine the government just one day
changes something and you now don't have
the same amount of money you did the day
before oh i don't need to imagine
so i'm just saying it was like he was up
he didn't like how that was so he wanted
to
create something that was more
decentralized where you couldn't do
something like that right and so he
created the value of
crypto to people is that it's
decentralized
so on that note though there is
also another side of that where it's
like when
when people get to the point where
they're like all money has
no value and it's all just
then you get into a complete other you
get to the other side of
this crazy perspective which is like
well then
then why don't why don't we just like
print a bunch of money and give it out
and there'll be no consequences to it
that's
we don't know anything about that
territory that's like
pointing a i mean we do they did it in
germany
what does that mean hyperinflation right
yeah so
that's definitely possible and we've
seen examples of that now
the head of the fed right now is saying
like yes we know
why there was inflation in the 70s and
the 80s
and we know all these other instances of
hyperinflation and we know
a lot about those yes but
also what he said was like right now we
don't
know if those same things apply
or if they don't and it's like it's like
a really weird
that's why things are so weird right now
is because
uh we've previously it's
it was like oh well this hyperinflation
in the 70s happened because this
hyperinflation in germany happened
because of that
hyperinflation in venezuela because of
that
now now it's like is there going to be
hyperinflation because of this
it's like well we have these tools all
the fed says it's like well we have
these tools
and uh you know we can use them
and uh we'll see what happens
and it's like whoa i don't know i don't
know what that means
you know because like yeah it's just
it's surreal sometimes like i
it could just be that the the world
economy has gotten to a level of
flatness where now it's sort of evolving
into another
like layer of itself that hasn't existed
before that's entirely possible but
it's also entirely possible that it's
not that case and we're just kind of
way off on a curve right now we'll see
what is what's the difference like
hyperinflation is
printing money is that the or is that
very basically
what it is or basically well we should
also be clear when we say printing money
we don't mean they're like
fire up those printers boys yeah i mean
that's what they did back in the
few zeros yeah that is referring to
germany in like the 30s
before world war ii before hitler rose
to power when it was like hyperinflation
was like such a big deal like
you had people literally wheel barreling
all of their cash to the store
yeah to buy groceries it happened in the
civil war with the southern currency it
happened it's happened it is when
there's like very
traumatic effects uh in the civil war
they
they kept printing it to and it wasn't
it wasn't even money
it what it was is uh it what it says on
the actual
uh confederate bills is it says
ten dollars will be paid upon a treaty
of peace
from between the confederate states and
the united states
um and and that's so it wasn't even it
was a credit
it wasn't even a it was a credit bill
and
effectively the dollar is still kind of
that it's like it's a federal reserve
note
it's like this is a note for a dollar
and it's not actually a dollar
um it's not no wait what
hold up the dollar bill is not a dollar
well
i mean keep in mind all money is just
representative a representation of
productivity and that's one of the
things
like if your productivity stays the same
but you went from having 100
into your inner economy to a thousand
dollars in your economy like
right all that's happening is the
representation of productivity to one
unit of your currency has just gone down
you know it's like so at the end of the
day you need to have
production to back the currency because
currency is just you know to
make it really derivative here currency
is just a way for us to
streamline the barter system mm-hmm you
know and
that's kind of one of the things like
regardless of all this inflation talk
and things like that you know obviously
you got to be aware of that but like at
the end of the day if you're productive
and you're like valuable to society yeah
you're good to the people around here
yeah if you have inherent value you will
continue to have inherent value
regardless of how much money
is floating in the system right okay
yeah sure
but yeah um uh a dollar is
uh uh
i mean this is people are probably gonna
tear me to shreds on this but there was
there was the uh all those economists
yeah graduate students listening to the
podcast yeah
gold standard and there was the silver
standard um we went off of those things
under nixon
uh and um when they're like wait we
don't actually have to have
all of the gold that we say that we have
this isn't enough
money things like this that's an
inherent thing that allows the economy
to prosper this is why there are so many
tools that the federal reserve has
to like regulate runaway situations
is because the the federal reserve the
reason why it's called the federal
reserve is because they reserve
an actual amount of money right that the
rest of the economy is based on and they
can loan
out if you're a banking institution you
can loan out up to nine
times the amount of money that you
actually have
man they gotta fix their security on
that system though because it's like i
saw
jeremy iron steal all of it
we're gonna lock you in the federal
reserve that's not how that works
then freaking bruce willis had to go and
get it back
so i'm making a uh die-hard three
three-year-old anyway i'm the extent of
my knowledge so if you guys
have more knowledge on this definitely
i'll be reading through the comments and
let me know
yeah because i always love a good
education from another
i do too it's actually one of the best
things about reading the comments yeah
yeah
yeah especially when we talk about stuff
we really know a lot about
so sam emailed me or forwarded me an
email that you guys have gotten on the
quarter email
because i'm learning houdini this dude
uh named edmund
uh belittle i forget your last name
sorry
uh basically there's this shot from
when they're doing a bunch of nuclear
testing it was like the apple ii test or
whatever
apple appletini doesn't matter epic
house blows up from a nuclear bomb
it was it's the famous shot where like
all the paint vaporizes on it
yeah and then moments later the shock
wave hits it and then just
crumbles and flies away yeah um
and it's it's it's insanely done because
he recreated it in houdini
wow like redesigned the house from
scratch procedurally using houdini's
procedural tools or watching
and then simulated it uh because what's
happening is that as the blast goes off
the heat uh from the blast travels at
the speed of light yeah and so it hits
the house instantly and all the paint
there
is suddenly a thousand degrees right
like it just vaporizes
right and so that's what you see like
floating off of the top of the house and
then the black blast wave hits it
yeah it looks like it sucks it back into
the blast
that's what's happening is because like
when the actual blast wave hits
that's it creates this low pressure zone
so like after every bomb honestly you
have that but a nuclear blast is on such
a
scale that you can actually see the wind
pulling back in it's like after a wave
you know
like a wave splashes on the ground and
then it pulls backwards like that force
actually
quite a bit to pull you back into the
ocean and so
yeah he just he recreated it very very
accurately i was very impressed that's
sorry go ahead how is houdini so far
it's interesting i haven't gotten very
far in fact i just did my first
render it's a ball on a concrete surface
it's super simple um i took a picture of
it and now it's on a crypto
art way i uh
it's uh
yeah it's it's right now i'm still
trying to wrap my head around all of the
different systems in place we're talking
about cops chops bops and sops and it's
like i'm just still trying to figure out
that
and so i'm actually on this uh this
mograph
uh course from this guy named mark
flancher called stop being afraid of
houdini it's a good title
yeah it's a great title and and it's
it's actually geared specifically for
cinema 4d artists so that's why i
i'm trying it out and i haven't gotten
very far
and what i've found about tutorials is
that
you have to reach a certain threshold of
understanding for the program before
they stop putting you to sleep yeah
right
and i'm at the stage where they're still
putting me to sleep it doesn't matter
how good the tutorial is i mean it's
just like
my brain just can't function for more
than like literally 30 seconds at a time
and i find myself just like so dense
well yeah
part of that is just my brain part of
that is also just like it's the aspect
of learning the the user interface all
the different
operators and systems and how the actual
program works and once you kind of get a
basic understanding
of all that then you can do the fun
stuff and then you no longer are put to
sleep
that's what it was like when i read that
civil war history
what yeah i had to under there's a fun
part after that though
there was a fun part after i had to
understand like all
the characters okay who are
participating and then like
i'd be like who's this like what what's
going on and there's half the time where
i would be like falling asleep and then
after i got through like the first book
i was like oh
okay i remember him i remember this and
then like by the third book i was like
dude this is great
i would love it if dan carlin did a
civil war podcast
he definitely should dan collin i know
you're listening
he's actually live right now he's damned
is actually behind this couch
reporting you know what i'm doing with
something yeah
that's cool though i mean it's like uh
it's like learning a new
superpower so it's a lot like learning a
new language yeah
is what i've come to figure uh and so
once i i
actually start getting to the point
where i can start producing things and
making things then
it's it's less about watching the
tutorials and more just like fumbling my
way through the
things and actually referencing the
parts of the tutorials when i need them
right carmichael actually said something
interesting today because me and dean
were talking about no way
hold on carmichael says interesting
things sometimes it was very surprising
to me
yeah me and dean were talking about how
uh specifically like key frames
didn't really do the kind of easing that
we wanted it to it just doesn't have the
level of control that it does in
premiere
and you have to flip the fusion to
really get that that level of using yeah
you're talking about davinci sorry yeah
in davinci yeah
um and he he just basically said he was
like well it's like
it's basically like how if you learn
french or you speak french you can't
communicate the exact same things
as efficiently or as quickly as you
could in english right
you're just not able to because the
language doesn't allow you to and you
have to you have to do certain things or
communicate it in a different way to
just you know achieve that level of
efficiency and that's what i was like
well
yeah i mean that means that we just need
to think more about
how we're using fusion in tandem with
with the edit page yeah and so that i'm
sure that
is the same thing with with houdini or
any other program that that's different
than the one that you
you know grew up using or have used for
you know years
about houdini though is it's like it's
so different from every other 3d program
out there it's different from blender
from cinema 4d from 3ds max for maya
it just the way it operates is very
different mm-hmm and
yeah yeah it's gonna feel i think the
hardest thing though about learning a
new program
it's like it's like skiing all your life
and you go to like whistler
and you start on a snowboard you're like
there's that mountain i just really want
to ski on the whole mountain but i hit
the green circles on my freaking
snowboard because i don't know how to do
it yet
that's like what it's like you know for
me like jumping into unreal it's like
i don't know anything i don't know where
anything is it's frustrating like
i know exactly what i want to do but i
know the technical specifics behind it
but it's like
where is that freaking check box time to
spend the next half hour looking for
that one check
box do you find it collectively do you
guys find that in these
in these learning experiences that there
is like
yes there's relearning the language and
there's similar words
for like the same thing or there's a
word for the same thing but then also
there's
also a fundamental basis of knowledge
that you have to have
where you need to think about problem
solving sometimes differently too
and like say well adobe would so
premiere would solve this problem this
way but in davinci
because of the way that it's built it
solves this problem this way yeah and so
that that's like a different
there's not a word for it there's not a
toggle for it in premiere there's
i mean a lot of the same principles do
transfer over between 3d programs
and once you learn those principles
they do they do help uh and then it is
mostly a matter of like okay
this is a new house with new shelves and
all my stuff is in here somewhere
that's right can we title the podcast
a new house with new shelves and all my
stuff is in here somewhere
that's that's what learning a new
program is like i think that's called
expanding your mind
i think that's what that's really called
i want to
look at the chat it's going to get
touched to the hit the three bars up at
the top
left where it says we're live oh you
don't have it you don't have it we don't
have it displayed
i had it displayed oh that's a that's a
chat
okay
yeah but we're in the app slash live
dash chat
oh i can just go to the oh guys welcome
to the party we're on corridor
digital.com
live chat scott i know you can hear me
right now turn it up
crank it up scotty
it's your boys gotta be coming in hot
don't know if your last name wasn't
beating it but that's funny
apparently it's uh glitching out a lot
so
jake's going off on in his own world
right now i saw you recently reached out
to um
somebody that had corridor.com yeah can
you tell me that story a little bit
yeah so uh there's a man
who owns cord or digital or sorry
corridor.com
and uh scott looked him up
and his he's from down under i can't
remember if it's new zealand or
australia
uh but he
has a twitter profile and scott found
him on twitter and one of the
one of his self proclamations of who he
is in his twitter profile is
professional [ __ ] talker
this will be fun he'd fit in great here
um so i
you know like a cl he's like a troll so
um
so i on his site he's got a
uh price on there site available for
lease and he's got the price on there
so for corridor.com yeah there's a price
yeah of course because he's trolling us
and so i uh emailed him and i was like
hey we'll pay you x for this
and he's like no price is on the site
and i was like yeah that's way too much
no one's gonna pay you for that
you should just say what it was i'm oh
yeah i'm gonna that was my punch line
okay he wanted 8 300 a month to lease it
oh
don't even get to own it yeah like dude
come on like
what are you what scheme are you trying
to run it no we're good dude i am
and like have fun wasting
away on this url because no one's gonna
buy it from you except for us
and the amount of money that i offered
which you could have had in your pocket
right now is apparently
what you're not gonna get it dude
some people haven't listened to that old
saying of a bird in the hand is worth
two in the bush it really is and you
know i've been saying that more and i
don't
i some reason why the heck do i keep
saying it too i said it today already
this is my second time saying
you love that first of all yeah but also
we say that to each other a lot
and i i've been saying it to other
people
and some people have never heard it and
i'm like
wait where's my nikko i need him
and why are you even holding a bird
because you caught a bird dude you got a
bird like that you can just like
just like it flew by my great uncle or
my great grandfather
yeah he used to ca he used to raise uh
uh mine mining birds
they weren't canaries they were a
variant of those
the ones they give them little pickaxes
and they go down to the tunnels
the canary with a little hard hat
actually the term canary in a coal mine
refers to a dead canary with a hard hat
and a pickaxe
those canaries worked hard back in the
day they deserve more credit no but i
i mean the phrase doesn't it speak for
itself a bird in the hand is worth two
in the bush yeah because you can't see
the bush birds
in the bush in the wild okay a bird in
your hand i took it
i always took it literally and i never
quite know there's one bush and there's
two birds in there and you're like there
they are like you might be
you might be able to see so it's like a
hunting analogy okay
like imagine you're hunting and you see
two birds and you're like well there's
two birds there
are those birds as valuable as the one
that you actually have already
gotcha i mean no like i understood i
understand the phrase
but i just never understood the
specifics of the words like two in the
bush it always sounds dirty to me for
some reason too with the bush
that's funny my wife and i she didn't
grow up uh
sorry she she learned english as she
grew up but english wasn't her first
language and so
there's all these english idioms that
she doesn't know and so sometimes we
have like
like for example her and her sisters
grew up saying
oh you're just sitting there like a pump
out of la
pop out a lot yes and she used to say
that
and i caught her one day and i said wait
what are you saying
she's like a pump out of law you know
like you're just sitting there wait
pump out of law pump like a
imagine you don't know english and now
imagine somebody says
you're just sitting there like a pump a
bump on a log but you don't hear you're
like bump on a log
bump on a lawn you wouldn't hear it you
wouldn't hear bump on a log
if you didn't speak english you'd be
like wait this is this phrase you just
spoke has
no makes no sense is this a word i got
you
yes you would your brain would naturally
be like okay
bumble the log that's a word uh-huh
you're just sitting there like a bump on
a law
and so then i was like no it's a bump on
a log and she's like what does that mean
i was like well nothing i mean it means
you're
you're not doing anybody any good you're
just a you're i've actually
never heard that phrase before the
phrase bump on a log no
no and you're from oregon you should be
i i spent the least amount of time my
life in oregon
i'm just i'm trying to draw i'm just
trying to draw on a conclusion
um yeah no it doesn't make any sense
other than
like what it is which is just i don't
know it's probably some old lager phrase
yeah okay here's a crazy thing that i
thought of the other day too wow
as long as we're on etymology and word
usage look don't look at gift horse in
the mouth jake
see there you go i like that one i've
never heard that wait hold on you never
said don't look a gift horse in the
mouth
a gift horse yeah as of today you've
never heard of that yeah until just now
really that's such a common one a horse
that you have like has a little bow on
it
no it doesn't mean you give it to
somebody you'll so you give someone a
horse they're like i'm gonna check the
quality of your horse and looking at the
teeth to make sure it's a good horse
because that's what you do i guess
oh god like what the heck's wrong with
you stop being picky i just gave you a
present
right yeah got it don't look my gift
horse in the mouth you [ __ ] yeah
am i doing that now no i just oh i just
wanted to say it
so anyways uh i went to the rodeo the
other day
you did i saw that and i was learning
about uh
like they have a they have this event
called steer wrestling
and so i was like what is a steer you
know i didn't grow up on a ranch i don't
know
a steer is a uh young male bull
who's been i believe the term is
castrated i don't know if that's the
same
oh and you remove the the the nuts isn't
it gelding
i don't know but either way you know i
don't know if casper not the whole
package right i don't know i don't know
if castration refers to like the
long part or the the long part i don't
know you know um but either way they
they remove the
uh testicles of the bull is it a
moon nick
that was pretty good running that was
pretty good that was such a sad joke
it's really good maybe it's not eunuch's
not really dad
anyways um so uh i was learning about
the types of cattle um and uh
so a male bull is called a bull right
and when he
you when you cut him off then he's when
it's young it's known as a steer
and then as it grows into adulthood it's
known as an ox
okay and in england and in in celtic
culture they they have a uh
it's a bull ox right it's like the same
word
in ox and bull and i don't know where
the
the the change between bull and ox
happened in english but in
in old english a any bovine creature
that you use for work is known as a
bullocks
so you're telling me that it's a load of
bullocks
so then then then that became a swear
word
and then the term bullocks is
yeah bollocks right and then they have a
bollocks knife which is a medieval knife
that
people used to carry that was used for
like cutting food and self-defense and
it was like a little dagger and the
reason why it was called that is because
it kind of looked like
you know a male package oh okay oh um
and
so then i was thinking about that and i
was thinking about bullocks and i was
like bollocks
and then [ __ ] which is our word
for the same thing and then
now and now we have this whole phrase
you go through all that etymology down
to down to two letters
we say that's bs and bs
refers to what you're actually referring
to when you say bs
and etymologists if you're listening
correct me but this is what i drew the
conclusion as
is you're saying that
your equivalent of a s of an ox
who is not a bull right you don't have
it
to to do the deed in terms of this like
cattle relationship to to
create another cattle so it's bs
isn't that weird that's super weird i
saw one of my favorite tweets of all
time today
it was someone did uh an aerodynamic
simulation of a cow
not very not very aerodynamic
nope this is a cow going hypersonic
oh that's a shockwave pattern off of
that that's really funny
so if cows could fly this is what it
would look like
this is like i i never knew i always
wanted to see this
it's a cow going hypersonic and a cow is
a female
cattle right obviously but we also use
it to refer to all cattle
which is also the same legal word
chattel which means personal property
comes from the word cattle
did you guys ever play the game hey cal
i'm i'm full of these i
went to law school this is all i got
from it
a lot of a lot of cow knowledge
etymology
which makes sense law is very much a
language based is it yeah they say when
you
get a law degree you're a doctor of
words not of
the law hmm word smith
is that why i call you dr justice hell
yeah brother
what is this cow game you're talking
have you ever played the game hey cal
no no basically when you're when you're
driving by a farm right
or you're like you're on a road and you
got like the fence next to you a bunch
of
cows out there yeah right you roll down
the window
and you lean your head out the window
and you yell
hey cow as loud as you can to see if you
can get the cows to run away
hmm it works really yeah
i've done it how close do you have to be
to the couch wow i i've done it from a
highway
hmm did you like do the ren scream at
them like a
full pitched like oh like it hurts i
feel so loud it hurts
and then you pass out yeah yeah but the
cows run away
and then one time i was like i whipped
up my phone camera and i was like all
right i'm gonna
i'm gonna get this on camera and then i
yelled at
at the cows and this is actually me at
the fence i've gotten out of my car
and was like looking at the couch i was
like i yelled at them and they didn't
move a muscle
they just like continued staring at me
and that was it that was
yeah wow fortunately there was a 20 bill
at my feet and then a dragon flew over
it's amazing
now that's a story right a good save
that's gonna be my default save for
everything but then i turned around and
there was a 20
bill and a dragon so i don't know
one saturday afternoon when i was like
14 years old as my dad's house out in
the country of minnesota i'm in the
backyard like
doing some chore and i look up and a cow
comes
rampaging over the long grass and jumps
into the yard and it's like
they started running at me and i ran and
jumped onto the dead side
it jumped over the fence no the long
grass like
there's like long grass render yard it
just comes just appears out of nowhere
it's just lurking just
running into the yard and sees me and
starting towards me like the cow running
at me
yeah yeah funny animals
yeah they kind of like they're like the
young ones are kind of like dogs they
look like a little bit
yeah and then they they kind of know
uh why i was watching them at the rodeo
and they know
kind of where to go and and and they
understand
uh the the function and purpose of of
like
people that are either interacting with
them or farming like
and and gates and and like where they
should and shouldn't be
um the first thing that the bull do
after the rider
is they'll they'll go for everybody
and and to get away from me and then
once they feel like it's clear
if they don't feel any threats then
they'll turn around and look for how to
get out of there and the first thing
that they do is look for the gates
oh yeah and then the people behind the
gates open it and usually the bull just
goes
and takes off back there does he charge
through the gates no they just kind of
they're not happy about it you know
they're not it's not like it hurts them
but what they do is they tie a
they tie a rope around there like around
their
um midsection yeah like but even lower
like around their waist
just above your genitals like like
right low low pelvis yeah pelvis like
low belly okay
i think it might be wrong but oh yeah
then they cinch it
and then they cinch it down and so then
once they cinch it then
that's what then the animal's trying to
get the cinch off
gotcha right right and then and then
after the rider is off
uh then the uh the
i don't know they're not the clowns i
don't know if they are the clowns or not
but the guys that are next to the bull
like keeping the rider safe
they'll grab the rope and untangle it
so they have to get right up to the bull
and pull this rope off of it
well it's all pissed off and like
kicking around it sounds so dangerous
it's super dangerous but it's an amazing
like
blend of like animal like
you know just like animals being animals
and like
humans like you know interacting and
commanding and trying to
control it's it's like it's a it's a
dance it's crazy
yeah and it's not it doesn't hurt
there's a lot of people who are like oh
rodeo's not good it's
it's fine because those bulls are worth
so much money and they get treated like
royalty
those bulls live better than honestly a
lot of humans
like they they're they got everything
that's bs
look at that full circle right there
jake
would you say this is your first rodeo
oh that was my first rodeo
yeah literally your first rodeo wow you
liked it was my first video i did
it was really cool i'll definitely go
again it was really interesting
cool yeah that's very texas of you i
guess i love how you're embracing just
all aspects of technology
i don't know what else to do man i mean
they're doing it and i'm like
what's the what's what do people do
around here and so they go
that's one thing i go okay i'll do that
i'm fine with that yeah that's really
intense like
i think the thing that really put it
into perspective for me was that jackass
thing you guys see the the thing with
the i think it was with um
stevo was on it oh sorry the video was
age gated i couldn't see it
we could talk about that here in a
moment if you want we should talk about
i think it's in three but they they do
like actual bull fighting
where they're like of course they're
like in their underwear or something but
they're trying to get up they're trying
to get a bowl to like
yeah nail them and and i think nail them
i think it's
actually it's johnny knoxville it just
gets just absolutely obliterated by this
did he always get killed because it
almost stomped on his head
oh yeah it did yeah yeah yeah and all
the time people die all the time in
rodeos yeah
um well they all wear you well you wear
helmets and
now all of them were still a bull's foot
to your sternum would just crush your
ribcage crush your rib cage yeah
it's it's it's just and they they wear
um they wear full pads oh my god
uh like on the chest oh my god
yeah this is so dangerous that's insane
nigga's showing us a video of these guys
on like freaking see-saw
bulls trying to hit them don't try that
at home kids
and so the modern the moderator fighting
that they do in rodeo
is uh they they have a barrel man
who's like the clown and like the guy
that gets the crowd riled up
and then he and the uh and the other
fighters
um oh god oh my god
yeah it's so bad that's those things
we can't show you this video otherwise
this video will also get agency most of
the time that stuff
doesn't happen because the people that
are in the arena aren't these guys
jackasses yeah um
wow man yeah uh yeah
yeah yeah so maybe they handle it a
little bit more professionally a little
bit better
like they they know the technical to
just
like you distract it with one hand and
then you go around the other side you
know like
the they they have all those sort of
practices to it and obviously their
intention isn't
to do this which is these guys are
intentionally trying to
rile this thing you know like right once
the riders off of it the intention isn't
to
rile it oh oh man
yeah get me out of there see that's
that's what i'm saying though is like
this look at that that's that [ __ ] put
it into perspective is that like how
how like much force is behind that no
that's
uh those things are just very powerful
animals and that one's a small
one yeah i would never want to get in
there with one of those things like that
one's not even that big
like even with padding and proper
precautions like oh my god yeah there
goes
there goes a rib yeah he's running from
adrenaline and fear of death
and johnny knoxville is dedicated yeah
he is i remember uh
hearing a story about what he thought
what was that most recent one like about
like the
amusement park or whatever yeah yeah and
he like they had a stuntman
doing the stunt and he's like it's not
good enough i need to do it he went in
there just he sends it and just [ __ ]
himself up
and he's like you know like for the next
lady 20 minutes on the ground
yeah i don't know i just it's weird that
he's driven to be like that
that's strange yeah always has been
clearly respected to a certain degree
but like
yeah and then at another degree you're
like why
are you okay yeah do we need to talk
yeah i mean there's got to be just a
level of insanity that those guys are
just on a different level in terms of
what they're willing to do
you know it's like yeah this guy had a
little bit of a death wish or something
yeah i don't know but then again he's
made it this far and he's still alive so
he's like i'm invincible his friends
have it yeah
yeah so stunning react on saturday
you didn't get the views it normally
would yeah on those
age gated yep uh because we had uh
rackaracka
and we had a scene from uh jackass
and so they age gated us um
yeah so to clarify what that means if
you don't know which you probably do
basically it's like you have to have a
youtube account and you also have to say
that you're older than 18 years old
it's just like to prove it you have to
prove it how do you prove it i've never
had to prove it
we might be uh grandfathered in slashing
knowing enough about us that it's like
they know we're not 18. um but yeah you
have to send them a picture your id your
credit card oh no
wow yeah wow
it also might be different for each
country so um
obviously that's something we try to
avoid heavily because
with the point of the react shows and
any content that we do isn't
isn't to have it be so
over the line of what's considered
acceptable
to you know we're not we're not out
there trying to find that line
necessarily now i know
we just did harry potter rated r but
also i think
everyone well understood that that was a
very specific context for that piece
and it was done with the intention of of
trying to like apply some of these
modern and more realistic techniques
to this magic um but
with the exception of like tiny guns too
we haven't really gone
out with a project of being like hey
let's just see if this gets demonetized
just to see if there's a line
out there or not um and so anyways
they age gated it and it was it's tough
for us because we try to make that show
uh that was a good episode too and yeah
lauren ray kim's awesome and it's like
she's talking about some really cool
stuff she did on mandalorian and it's
like
yeah it would have been really cool to
share that with as many people as
possible exactly the idea is to feature
her
to feature her work is really
unfortunate educate people on why it's
cool so that the next time they see the
mandalorian or they see her
they know like who she is and why and
and the sort of art of the performance
that goes into it that's that's the idea
and so
you know but not every can't win them
all you know that's just that's just the
way it goes sometimes and
uh yeah it's unfortunate because i wish
there was a system where youtube could
just
white list channels knowing like okay
everything you're gonna get from
game theorists or quarter crew or you
know like
that have this history of years and
years and years of pouring
money and resources into the platform to
create
uh a show format that it like people
return to
and is also like considered
you know to be uh well open to a wide
audience
i mean the point still stands though if
they they would have still had to age
gate the video
because it doesn't matter whether or not
we were whitelisted it's like it the
video itself they still deemed as being
you know not suitable that's what i'm
saying i think maybe they should do that
at the channel level
not at the video level but then okay so
they do that at the channel level but
then we could have still released that
video
and it wouldn't have been age gated and
then that would have gone against
what youtube would have preferred i know
and that's
what if we decided to like go to this
random japanese foreign
so much different yeah they know the
reason why i'm saying we could do the
reason why is because
when the their big policy the thing that
they want to stay away from
with respect to acts is are these easily
replicable by miners
and i i get that but it's also
that's one of those policies where their
their philosophy is
well if we're just a little bit more
heavy-handed
then we need to be then overall it's for
the
greater good and that's their fault
that's their philosophy there it's the
same thing with
uh anytime you're doing a video that
shows when we did the sniper camera
anything that can be construed as how to
manipulate a firearm
or or uh adjust a firearm you know
mechanically
right they they're so adverse
to anything that could be conceived of
that obviously we found another one we
didn't know that at the time we made
that sniper video we were like this is
fine we're
we're using a receiver from an airsoft
that was a great video too and it was
like it's for photography
for photography yeah that video is super
underperformed
right and so we we didn't know that at
the time well
here we found another one and so i just
don't know how many of these
are out there i think at this point we
just accepted that
you know of the year you're gonna hit
five to ten videos that
get blocked on some thing or another but
i just
i wish and i don't mean to bash everyone
bashes on google and youtube i think
they do a lot
to try to keep their platform arguably
youtube is like
the the most socially responsible social
media platform out there and it still
has problems
don't get me wrong pretty low bar yeah i
think i think youtube is still very
exploitative of miners
right um and it shouldn't be but uh
you know it's not tick-tock
so you know whatever uh so anyways
i don't mean to be debbie downer i just
uh it's interesting because
we have to factor that in now and i wish
there was a little bit more of a
i guess a process that channels could go
through with them as they
like as you come up you start you're
just creating videos you're just trying
to make
trying to make ends meet you're trying
to get your following you're trying to
make your
uh format you're trying to you know
do that you're trying to contribute to
the platform well i wish as people came
up
through starting out and going through
the process that there was a little bit
more of a
process directly with youtube to say
okay
i've been doing this for five years like
take take a team
and and review like the whole of our
library
and give us like a decision like is our
library like something where
you can say safely say like as a
platform like hey we stand behind us
have a sign a contract
you know like whatever but like there
should be a little bit more of that
interaction i think
then again you know who knows how many
other channels are out there that are
bigger than us maybe we're a small fry
there's so many big channels now yeah
it's like looking at cities in china man
you're like
cool there's like this city's got five
million people and that city's got 10
million people and they're all bigger
than l.a
you know it's like and you never this is
maybe just me being ignorant but
you never heard of them you know and
it's like dude
20 million people live there yeah it's
like it's bigger than l.a
wow there's so many channels out there
now that's how i feel
it's like yeah it's kind of scary and
it's also bubbled out so like you don't
cross the borders into other bubbles you
just never know they exist
yeah yeah okay a little bit when when
you get to like the end of the year like
when mr beast did his whole like uh
his own youtube rewind thing and it's
like
it's it's representative of mostly what
he
considers to be youtube you know and it
doesn't really touch a lot of facets
that other people consider to be youtube
yeah which is funny because like last
year we were on the trending page
pretty much every weekend yeah you know
so theoretically we're gonna
do a youtube rewind maybe the one show
that hits the training page
every week for a year would be a show
that would be uh
the rewind but it's not and and i'm not
i'm not bothered by it it's just i
find it interesting that like you know
every every
it's all subjective and you're we're all
looking at my view of youtube
and and who are the big creators of
youtube doesn't even touch
a fraction of the huge creators out
there yeah and
and i'm like because like you're saying
it's like oh wow this guy has 13 million
subscribers i've never heard of this
person in my life yeah
and there's a thousand of them no
seriously
it's and it's really cool that they're
able to establish an ecosystem that's
that robust like
that's so
i don't think anyone ever thought it
would be like that when it first started
that there would be that many yeah
like opportunities for people and
there'd be that
wide and large of an audience globally
you know it's pretty remarkable do you
think what that means though is that
youtube might not have the resources to
do what you're proposing
which is to like yes it could be that
yeah
it definitely could be but you know they
are owned by alphabet
and i i'm not saying like oh they're big
companies you got all the money in the
world so you should just waste a bunch
like i'm not saying that either but if
logic stands that if you had a company
with
that large and not enough resources that
you would
you would think hey maybe there's a
practice that we can employ and make it
efficient and
economical for uh the people that are
involved and we can find a way to do
that without
losing money yeah um i think that at
least
somebody's would look into it and maybe
it's just not
maybe it's so far down on the like nitty
gritty level
of of people that are actually creating
for the platform that maybe it's
something that's just overlooked
you know could i play this out with my
handpan oh dude
yeah real quick though i i want to i
want to mention something it's like
uh just going back to what we're talking
about a moment ago with the thousands of
channels that are all huge it's like
corridor
as a company with our even if you're to
combine all our channels together we're
not even in the top like ten thousand of
channels
what maybe okay sure i made that up i
don't know
definitely are we though let's double
check that my point is that
i checked it frequently i'm gonna check
i'm gonna check back if you can sorry
just go
one step further if you combine corridor
and corridor crew we're in like the top
thousand well if you
combine them if you combine them okay
still then we combine them
nico i suggested combining them years
ago
no never happened
my point being though is that when i
started with corridor in 2012
corridor was a top 100 youtube channel
yes yes
77 was the top yeah because i remember
joining when we were just
under a hundred and then we slowly
started climbing up over a hundred
or sorry under 100 and down and like it
was it was really cool of course freddy
at the time was like number five
yeah the freddie w channel rather three
i think uh yeah they got in and i was
like that was a big deal and then
slowly over time it was just like it's
not that we
lost popularity we've only continued
gaining popularity since then but the
speed at which we've done that is not
nearly as fast as
everyone else on the platform who has
rocketed up past us that's
true and not true we've we have
like we've had different phases okay
you're absolutely yes
we have gone through phase because i
yeah i got a new phone recently
and i went to the store over the weekend
to get the sim card installed
and the guy uh putting in my uh
card he was like he waited until he had
my name down he's like
i love your stuff he's like oh hey
what's up
likewise when i ordered some stuff from
sweetwater music and the guy you know
he's like okay we got all this stuff i
should be there in two weeks also
uh she's looking to serve ninjas for
something react
suggested it's like a comment but he
left
but my point was that he had no idea who
we were before last year he started
watching all our videos through
uh once quarantine started and most of
most new viewers only know us from the
quarter crew channel and they have no
idea that we made all these hyper viral
videos you know
six seven years ago yeah and and they
like and i see this a lot people like
i'll get tweets and they're like oh my
god i had no idea you were the guys who
made this video
i fell in love with you last year but it
turns out i fell in love with you eight
years ago
and just forgot all the time i've loved
you
it's just funny i mean we've been on
this platform for so long now that it's
like
you have those phases and people only
know those phases they don't know your
whole history
it also goes to show how bad of a
business model viral videos are for
audience retention that's an interesting
point you think about
people's habits on the platform like
most people
aren't i don't think there's a lot of
people who have been
on the platform consistently since the
beginning
as a consumer of content the only ones i
can think of are like written link
no i'm saying like as a consumer
consumer sorry i thought you'd think
talking about
you i have been a consumer since the
very beginning yeah i mean i guess i
have two i just don't i don't know i
uploaded my first video
in may of 2006.
anyway we are 2916
subscriber ranking on corridor crew what
would say that number again
2916. on corridor quarter crew oh
hit
yeah by the way it's worth mentioning
corridor you can't
give me any attention it's old right
right
but before before before christian
throws that quarter i just want to point
out
like we're still going to make corridor
videos don't worry but like you know
this past year especially the pandemic
and everything else going on it's become
a you know
a thing in the background yeah quarter
still blows quarter crew out of the
water
with numbers which is nuts well
1064 for the top 1000 nikkei
that is actually that is better than i
expected to be honest video view rank 2
500.
and that's and that's the channel that
we don't even wait what's the video on
right now
you said that's youtube 2500 a higher
number than 1000 so that's not better
i'm sorry i'm perspective to the
corridor crew
oh gotcha i got you gotcha yeah well
it's because we got those videos that
have like a hundred million views on it
that's because
there's that 150 mil view the world's
longest lightsaber
50 mil no that's more 150 there you go
we should make another one of those that
was fun yeah
just use cam track ar so don't track the
shots anymore
yeah it's crazy like corridor gets more
subscribers per day than quarter crew
now today picks up more subscribers in
quarterback
full of that video idea
nicole this is a terrible idea
hey if it makes you feel any better both
carmichael and i
scoffed at your idea of doing uh vlogs
that's true this is like
december 2015 and you're like what if we
started doing like
daily vlogs and both carmichael and i
were like
no one would watch that for a long time
no one did
yeah all right i'm going to take us out
but before we do i'm going to tell
everybody a little bit about my brand
new hand pan yes sir
so i got this on friday i put in the
order back in uh october
i believe so it turns out there's a
handpan craftsman actually a whole
workshop uh in glendale uh nirvana
handpan and acolyte instruments
one of the people who were listening to
the podcast was actually trying to make
his own handpan
and hit them up and got a job there oh
no that's awesome
yeah which is cool so um you know hand
pans usually don't come
in stainless steel usually there are
different other forms of steel
but stainless steel resonates uh very
very nicely
however it's very hard to work so this
pan the guy was working on it
he actually threw it away halfway
through and started over
well yeah that's just one their
commitment to quality is really up there
but two it also it's how hard stainless
steel is to work
yeah and it's like and it also just
reinforces that the value
isn't in the material it's the
craftsmanship oh yeah definitely i mean
i think that's the thing for almost any
like nice instrument too
but uh the other cool things about it is
i got oops i got an extra note on the
bottom
oh point it to the camera so they can
see it yeah
and then i dropped a note on the top my
other hand
had a b flat which was the sixth
interval on the scale
i dropped that one because you don't use
the six too often in minor scales and i
added an octave
at the top because you know the knock
the the root note is kind of resolving
note you know like
like you need that to finish your phrase
right so when you're doing your little
solos and stuff you can uh
get in there but the hand pan resonates
very nicely
oh you can hear all the dedication
in the vibrations you can you can hear
all that another nice thing about the
resonance is you can get that wah
effect let's see if you can hear it
through this microphone
yeah point it right in there
so it's what i'm doing is i'm waving my
hand over i'm not touching the handpan
i'm literally just waving my hand
over the zone that i hit and it disrupts
the sound waves and because
see that's what i i'm confused about so
it's like you're waving the air around
and that's what's disrupting it because
i asked you
what would it not work if you have your
hand like parallel to the surface
no because i was thinking maybe it would
be like reflecting the sound waves off
your hand but it works this way
yeah it's weird and she's like okay so
maybe it's an air thing
maybe maybe maybe maybe the sound waves
are bouncing off your hand outwards and
and this is just it's
i don't know it's called a walk you walk
to the vibration yeah you wash
the note
this i would explain it i don't get it
either so okay hand pan
is that the actual official name of this
instrument so the very first handpan was
called the
hongdrum and i can't remember it's made
by a guy who is swedish
or swiss because they kind of become the
same thing in my mind even though
they're definitely not
um so anyways you just started a war
so hong is the either swedish i think
swiss actually must be swiss because
hong is i think the swiss term for hand
okay so hand drum and it was basically
the guy
made sound sculptures uh needless to say
they cost 10 grand and he had to write
an essay to even be considered and so on
and so forth but people
little by little kind of got their hands
on them and they're like wait
on them yeah exactly so for a long time
people call them the hang drums
you know they kind of give an
americanized accent uh however that's
the
brand name for that specific sound
sculpture from that specific
company okay uh so this is not a hang
drum this is a hand panned
because it's not made by that you know
whatever that company is in swiss
kleenex versus tissue right exactly uh
so needless to say i have it it's in the
key of d minor
i've been waiting for it for a long time
and i think it sounds lovely and i'm
going to play a little bit of it as we
end the podcast here sounds great let's
go
gentlemen if you're interested in
joining us live
consider subscribing to
quarterdigital.com
where we have exclusive shows an entire
vlog
just dedicated to the crazy things we do
around here
we've also got a show called functional
filmmaking
brought to you by david carmichael the
one and only
i bet you didn't know that his first
name was david now you do
because he listened to the podcast
all right wake up everybody oh what
happened
is it tomorrow watching or listening
both